[Musik]
oh mein Gott
[Applaus]
Leute ihr seht es bereits im Titel
eingeblendet wie reagieren heute
zusammen auf die zweite Folge von krass
Klassenfahrt sie geht fremd oh mein Gott
ich
habe überhaupt keine Erwartungen
rhinoshield Ehre mal schauen wie auf der
Chemnitz heute sein Handy fallen lässt
das ist jetzt was in der letzten Folge
geschafft das kann ich euch aber auch
kurz erklären und zwar ist eine Berliner
Schulklasse gerade auf Klassenfahrt
irgendwo auf dem kompletten Dorf
und innerhalb der Klasse gibt es voll
komische Leute und auch Streit und
Eifersucht und so weiter und so fort das
Hauptthema der letzte Folge war
allerdings dass die Jolene das ist die
Dieter mit den zwei unterschiedlichen
Augen die Joline ist mit dem Kenneth
zusammen
und die Joline liebt den Kenneth aber
nicht so doll wieder kenne die Joline
liebt und deswegen will die Joline
Fremdgehen heute Abend mit einem Jungen
namens Stanley das ist der hier
also es wird spannend
wieder sein Handy fallen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
krass Klassenfahrt oh mein Gott
der ultimative Test und nein der letzte
ein paar Sekunden in der neuen heutigen
zweiten Folge krass Klassenfahrt und was
macht kenwitz er lässt direkt wieder
sein Handy hier fallen oh nein das
gibt's doch nicht
gesagt von Rhinos
diese Krone so bescheuert aber auf der
anderen Seite auch echt große Respekt an
Rider Shield das sieht das so am
durchwinken lassen
ich glaube das war keine gute Idee
oh mein Gott das ist doch eine Option
Helikopter Crash Test gemacht und es ist
ganz geblieben ohne Scheiß sag mal hast
du zulegen gesehen die ist die ganze
Zeit bei mir
Joline
die ist wahrscheinlich gerade schon am
Fremdgehen und ich habe Statistiken
gelesen ganz viele und der häufigste der
größte Grund für Trennung sind Affären
wirklich mit irgendjemand anderem
schreiben das wäre schon ganz schön mies
ja ich mache es richtig aggressiv dass
du ihn die ganze Zeit mit Jungs
schreibst irgendwas verheimlicht sie mir
ja
gut erkannt mit deinen drei Gehirnzellen
kenne was machst du denn überhaupt warum
hast du deine Sachen dabei ich wollte
Sie fragen ob ich vielleicht doch hier
übernachten könnte weil
die will bei seiner Lehrerin übernachten
also wer mag es ihm verübeln du kannst
nicht bei mir übernachten
ich kann davon von der Schule fliegen
ich wollte sie auch nur kurz warten dass
die der anderen Schüler heute ein
saufabend machen wollen
hasse solche Leute einfach rumpetzen
dann bei der Lehrerin
was haben die denn davon
verstehe nicht schlecht also so ein
bisschen was trinken lassen
Schlafplatz ich drück dir die Daumen
Hammer Lehrerin einfach auf einer
Klassenfahrt sagen hey wenn ihnen
saufabend mache ist doch gut dass die
ein bisschen was trinken und hey mein
lieber Georg ich hoffe du findest einen
Schlafplatz
ich fahre gerade draußen für die Jungs
ein bisschen
Handy umgeworfen und so
ich war gerade draußen mit den Jungs ein
bisschen Handy rumgeworfen und so und
ich kann Jolina verstehen dass sie da
keinen Bock mehr drauf hast schreibst du
da das geht dich nichts an ich habe mit
den Jungs gesprochen und die meinten es
ist okay wenn man in einer Beziehung mal
nachfragt wie man so schreibt ich habe
ja auch kein Mädchen
Beziehung unsere Beziehung läuft schon
lange nicht mehr
scheiße ich bin super enttäuscht von
Joline wir hatten letzte Sache seit drei
monatiges und ich habe eine Collage mit
Lautern Bildern zusammengestellt keine
Ahnung einfach dass ihre Manuel zu
verändern Alter der heult ja richtig
lass doch lieber noch ein bisschen
Handys fallen wir sind seit drei Monaten
in einer Beziehung und jetzt reicht es
langsam mal wollen wir heiraten und
Kinder machen wir wollen doch alle nur
unseren Spaß ist so die sind noch drei
Monate für eine Beziehung reicht doch
vollkommen aus weißt du was mir vor
allem hier auf der Klassenfahrt richtig
klar geworden ist
die ganzen Jungs alle viel zu
oberflächlich für mich sind
Cheyenne
Cheyenne sagt dass die ganzen Jungs viel
zu oberflächlich sind
ich kann mir noch daran erinnern der
erste Satz von cheyenne war könnte genau
jetzt im Hilton sein in Moskau bei
meinen Eltern und wo bin ich
drechsloch aber ja klar
Cheyenne alle Jungs sind zu
oberflächlich ich glaube ich bräuchte
einen Freund der wirklich tiefgründig
ist emotionales und mir sein wahres Ich
zeig ja hat mich auch eine schöne Pussy
richtig oder und da bin ich hier auf
jeden Fall falsch ja ab nach Moskau
Digger deswegen bin ich so froh dass ich
heute mal hier bin
dir allein auch schon reden deswegen bin
ich so froh dass ich heute mal hier bin
am Gewässer sind das irgendwelche
kulturellen Zwänge oder ja also es ist
halt einfach Georg hallo
[Musik]
Cheyenne braucht wirklich so ein
tiefgründigen Jungen
ja coole Story obwohl ich brauche gar
nichts sagen
[Gelächter]
ja da sollte man mir auf jeden Fall
nicht folgen mädels was haltet ihr davon
mal ganz kurz kann sie bitte ihre
Leggings das nächste Mal noch höher
tragen was haltet ihr davon heute
richtig zu saufen
ach komm schon seid dabei
Georg tut mir echt leid ich erinnere
mich noch als er sich warm alle Pflanzen
in unserem Schulgarten kümmern musste
Stanley wollte ihm einen Streich spielen
und hat dann alle Pflanzen mit Deospray
angesprüht und dann angezündet ich
verstehe nicht warum die Leute so gemein
zu Georg sind
alle wer kommt denn auf die Idee alle
Pflanzen mit Deo anzusehen und dann an
die Hand
jetzt sind sie da bei dem saufabend
glaube ich oh da geht mir ordentlich ab
sogar Georg hä sogar georg ist da also
das ist übrigens der Typ der mit der
Jolene dann irgendwie ne
oh
über was
war wichtig gerade war wichtig aber wir
trinken später ein Jahr wir trinken noch
ich komme wieder gleich
machen gehen oder
raus was ist hier denn los
zusammen draußen sind musst du nicht
heißt dass die beiden noch zusammen sind
wir haben bald in der Schule
Projektwoche vielleicht planen die
einfach zurück zusammen stimmt
ja die machen gerade das Projekt für
Biologie bei dem äh ne aber vielleicht
sollte ich auch mit rausfinden mit dem
zusammen das Projekt machen
ja ist doch Hammer dann habt ihr einen
Dreier Projekt
also für die Schule dann also ich soll
sie eigentlich nicht sagen aber
vielleicht gehst du wirklich mal besser
nachschauen was die machen Projektwoche
habe ich doch gesagt
ja Dennis
Projektwoche boah ist der voll Alter
das macht er jetzt oh jetzt kommt sogar
so eine Effekt rein
oh nein ach sein Handy
diese Korb ist echt der Wahnsinn
oh mein Gott
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht genau
das
das war's die Folge ist an der Stelle
vorbei also das war so ca der
beschissenste
Cliffhanger bzw der beste Cliffhanger an
der Stelle dann den ich je gesehen habe
also ich bin auf jeden Fall gespannt wie
es weitergeht wie bereits gesagt wenn
ich mir die dritte Folge nächstes
Wochenende zusammen mit euch anschauen
soll dann schreibt's mir gerne in die
Kommentare lasst einen Daumen Hoch bei
diesem Video da und jetzt kommt das Auto
[Musik]